yann 36 coups dit aujourd'hui se trouve
une oreille face aux gars est basé sur
un nouveau mode de jeu appelé extrême
football direction très simple j'aime
pas besoin d'expliquer c'est un mélange
entre un match de rugby et de foot voilà
je vous laisse voir ça et moi je m'en
vais me faire un bon cassoulet tu crois
que tu cherche quelqu'un yann j'ai fait
clic droit au sénat ont lu après tu veux
pas plaqué qui toi ma fille quand elle
rockets alors ça vaut bien des
poursuites c'est pourquoi les fossés ya
quelques soucis l'ongle à la trop longue
ce qui laisse tu fais mouillart c'est ça
qu'on veut
les pôles de dépenses et l'arrêt tu fais
pour harry potter la calme toi je lui
donnais pour bien des fossés et accru
les canevas compte
harry potter s'est pas lavé en technique
à faire what i'm j'ai l'habitude de
tenir des trucs comme ça
allez on en fait parce que produit la
mécanique arrête de faire leurs
hypothèses ça marche mal on sait pas et
foncez
tu fais quoi avec ta voiture y habitent
ça passe ça passe dans harry potter
olala l'ange gardien ou laqué vue oui
c'est bon et le dernier pixar voilà non
mais il s'en fout lui une médaille d'or
face à la vanille est belle elle est
sortie de la folk arrête de faire de
harry potter
il est vrai il est vrai on peut observer
un certain relâchement je fais quoi toi
oui barons du bourg et je suis
monégasque lac de jus de pomme elle et
toi tu fais quoi toi tu fais quoi
auj
le jeune alors jeté là confie si ils
arrivent à une école à la race et marc
bourgeois et policiers sur eux
j'ai fait exposés quelque chose tu fais
grand ego sa vague au jeune arrière
j'en ai dix kilos j'en ai des cadeaux le
but est ouvert aux chansons sur l'amour
les rentrées dans les cages genres et
les styles c'est la victoire des blues
ont changé l'équipe ou pas mais le fait
pendant lé v de la [ __ ] ailleurs nous
venons au oui il arrête maman oui aller
aux états unis kddi
bien joué bien joué le terrain de rugby
le plus perdu au monde à l'état est
refusé aux cimaises du bien wiens avait
un tiens qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
attention et d'artois d'air pour le net
il volait depuis les attentats temps il
a fait quoi toi
d'accord je tourne autour battle de
roquettes mais qu'athènes requête mais
l'une watts bonjour 3 0 de quoi m lulu
de bonne humeur
ok je tente non lâchement la fusée s'te
plaît aux pêches
mais voilà trop tard ah si tu peux pas
je peux pas lâcher à seat en avant mais
j'arrive et voilà les gens c'est déjà la
fin de cette vidéo sur le mode extrême
football j'espère ça vous a plu cck
n'était pas aimé la vidéo ça fera
vraiment cassoulet je sais le cassoulet
de tout à l'heure il est bas le passé on
se retrouve très vite dans sa nouvelle
vidéo chat ou le monde - les pistes